A drug is any chemical that influences biological processes when introduced
into the body. Now, it's really important to know that drugs don't introduce
any novel physiological responses in the body, or in the brain. Rather, drugs
can disrupt our homeostasis. Within our body, we maintain our internal
environment within certain limits. For example, our body maintains things like
our temperature, our water content, our sodium content, even our heart rate.
Our resting heart rate is between 40 and 100 beats per minute. But,
methamphetamine can push our heart rate way out of this range in unsafe levels
of over 200 beats per minute. So, we see here that methamphetamine doesn't
cause any new responses in our body. We already have a heart rate, doesn't
create that. But it affects the homeostasis, so it increases our heart rate.